what's going on guys
so sharknado 2 is coming out later this
month the hype is swirling there's a
great white hype around the great white
shark and that got me thinking is that
part of a new generation of cult movies
what makes a cult movie we're gonna talk
about that very thing today in some of
our favorite cult movies we have a cool
panel to chat about it with first he is
a writer from Comedy Central's key and
Peele you've seen him on Parks and Rec
and he's also been in a cult movie
himself hatchet to Colton Dunn hello
everybody
she is the chief film critic of the LA
Weekly and she also has a book about Tom
Cruise and his movie stardom Tom Cruise
anatomy of an actor Amy Nicholson hi and
I reviewed hatchet - I know I read your
review so let's talk about cult films
for a second what makes something a cult
movie the first thing that I would say
to define a cult movie is that it cannot
announce itself as a cult movie ok for
something to have an actual the the
title of a cult film it's a it's a
sleeper like nobody knows about it
nobody likes it and slowly it builds up
a following one from the 70s I think
falls into that category Harold and
Maude um another film from the 70s that
is maybe the cult movie Rocky Horror
that is probably the biggest one up
until now the room that I've heard of
where people will go into a large group
into a theater regularly like say the
lines back at the movie yeah I see you
shiver with anticipation so um we
started to narrow it down and we think
there are three basic categories of cult
films a good movie that no one saw
really cheesy so bad it's good and then
just weird as hell we haven't put
anything in the second category yet
exactly real category really cheesy so
bad it's good yeah the happening I don't
know if it's that good even yeah it's
bad like this but it is it does have
some like great moments in there and
it's that I think a lot of it has to do
with Mark Wahlberg his very first line
in that movie is ridiculous he's like
talking to students and he asked him if
they learned about the bees disappearing
look I don't know if you got
heard about this article New York Times
about honeybees vanishing he's not a bad
actor he's done other stuff in your life
he's good but for some reason in this
movie he is always off every line he
says is off planning on stealing
something
no ma'am we're not plan on murdering me
in my sleep
what no the best quote movies have an
earnestness to them like the guy who
made the room there's nothing cynical
about that movie alright I got the
results of the test back I definitely
have breast cancer it is serious it
doesn't seem like there's any it's not
laughing at itself at all although he
says in retrospect oh no I was making it
as a comment [ __ ] thing that thing
is idiotic
how much is it it'll be $18 go keep the
change
hi doggie you're my favorite customer
thanks a lot bye
troll - I think it's uh oh yeah I'm
going it definitely like they were
serious about it like all those actors
who were in it will thought they were
doing serious work and I mean it is
ridiculous
let's hear from you guys at personal
favorites well some of my personal
favorites come from John Carpenter I'm a
big fan of assault on precinct 13 and I
love tons of Peter Jackson's earlier
movies like bad taste and meet the
Feebles I think those guys fall into
like this group of like directors who
just have a love and a specific vision
that I call it fu n like you watch that
movie and it's fun you could tell that
the director was having fun and that
they have that I you know that element
of cutting corners cuz they're just
trying to get their idea made and make
it happen and it's not polished it's not
fresh but it's just a silly fun idea
yeah that's what I love about movies Amy
any favorites yeah there's a couple
there's a small cult of us film critics
who are really worshipping at the altar
of macGruber like that's the movie that
when when I left the theater I was like
everybody loved that right and then
everyone hated it and I was so confused
yeah but I feel like history will bear
me out and then I want to give kind of a
shout outs one of those accidental cult
movies Oh have you guys heard of Miami
connection I haven't so in the 80s there
was a Taekwondo master and he had a
Taekwondo school and he wanted to make a
movie highlighting his students so he
made this film called Miami connection
released it only in like three or four
theaters in Orlando and Howe and Miami
it made zero money they called them up
like decades later they're like we found
your movie and to me that's the way a
cult film should go are there any movies
that are considered cult films that
you're not a fan of I would say I would
say you have to be careful and it said
it's okay if you don't like a cult movie
that's okay because that called movie is
for a specific person or personality and
they'll be and they'll get a call money
for you sometime you'll find yours but
like a cult movie it has by definition
its name it's a cult is small and
specific not everyone's gonna like it if
everyone loves it it's the sleeper yeah
like yeah of course people love a good
movie when they realize it's a good
movie um are there any cult films that
you are like I just I do sort of object
to this deliberate cultivation I object
on principle to sharknado
I just object yeah a really sad example
of it is what happened to snakes on a
plane you know cuz that was a movie that
was made to be kind of serious and then
when it became an internet joke eight
months before it was released they added
in
stupid jokes and then we didn't actually
work yeah by trying to capitalize on the
potential of making a cult movie I think
they killed it I've had it with these
[ __ ] snakes on this mother good
boy and to what your scent yeah like The
Asylum films I mean yeah there is some
Kitsch and fun to it but a lot of it is
like soulless and it's like well those
guys are just like straight out thieves
right yeah me like Pixar be honest the
the that company their whole goal is to
just make a movie you know like say
aliens gonna come out they'll come out
with a movie called alien yeah you know
right before it and their whole goal is
just to make money so Oh
instead of Pacific Rim they did Atlantic
rest yeah Abraham Lincoln vampire hunter
they did a billion versus I don't want
to talk about before like snakes on a
train where snakes on a train yeah and
so it's like you have the low budget you
have the cutting corners but you're
missing that crucial aspect that we
talked about where there's an artistry
to it there was a passion behind it and
that doesn't exist in the asylum movies
they have the low budget they have all
that but there's just no passion
yeah and Sarah T is the one that's why
they should hire me to write their
movies right because I bring the passion
to it and they can keep it just as
low-budget and I could just write the
craziest [ __ ] and then then Amy would
review you can review it and you'll talk
about it I'll come jot it right here on
screen
so what's your favorite cult movie of
all time leave us an answer in the
comment section below
the best answer we're gonna send you
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
my guest Colton Dunn
Amy Nicholson boom and I also want to
thank a good friend of ours
Jamie Rodgers Jamie happy birthday
thanks for watching the show buddy
and I want to thank you for watching I'm
Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter my bike
now 20 years later
they're back but this time we are
bringing the fight to them and in space
everyone can hear freedom ring